[Music]
the cons grow on trees that are native
to South Central North America in fact
pecan is an Algonquin word that means a
nut that takes a stone to crack today
computerized shelling machines do that
job for you
pecans had flavor and crunch to any
recipe they can also be a satisfying
treat on their own but manufacturing
pecans is an entirely different nut to
crack at harvest time the husks that
contain the nuts
start to open at this orchard a machine
grabs the tree-trunks and shakes the
nuts to the ground
[Music]
once on the ground a sweeper moves the
pecans away from the trees and into a
row it also blows away some of the
lighter debris a harvester with paddle
wheels collects the pecans
once on the harvester the pecans ride
chain conveyors as vacuums remove and
discard debris then the pecans are
transferred to a cleaning plant the
pecans are unloaded into a pit and a
conveyor takes them inside the pecans
funnel into a slotted drum and tumble
around the drum sorts the Dee husk
pecans from those that have retained
their husks in this enclosed machine
spinning wire brushes remove more of the
husks blowers release the lighter husks
into a bin to be disposed of later after
more processing pictures of the nuts are
taken with cameras a computer monitors
the pictures for any husks still
attached to the pecans if any are
identified the computer activates a
blower to remove them
with the husks removed harvesters sort
out any of the pecans that are cracked
or split open at this point the pecans
contain about 12% moisture which is high
enough to cause deterioration so
harvesters leave the pecans to dry for
24 hours to lower the moisture content
to 4% once drying is complete the pecans
are transferred to the shelling plant
where they are plunged into a chlorine
and water bath this both cleans them and
rehydrates them without sufficient
moisture the pecans will break into bits
during cracking and the objective is to
extract intact halves for retail the
pecans are rinsed in water at a
temperature of 180 degrees Fahrenheit
this step removes chlorine residue
sanitizes the pecans and raises the
moisture content to seven and a half
percent now it's time to get cracking
with a completely automated process
inside the shelter pistons hit each end
of a nut simultaneously cracking it
cleanly the D shelled pecans travel
across a vibrating sifter that sorts
them by size then the pecans fall in
front of an electronic system which
releases a blast of air that removes any
lingering shell pieces a second sifting
system removes any additional small
pecan bits these pecans will be
processed into candy bars and commercial
pastries the electronics order has
removed most of the shells but not all
of them
technicians visually scan the pecans and
pick out the remaining shells
the pecans continue along the conveyor
and fall into cardboard boxes at the end
of the line to prepare a toasted pecan
snack food salt and butter are added to
the nuts then the nuts are cooked and
mixed in a roaster in packaging
technicians pour the pecans into
measuring jugs then empty them into
plastic bags hot jaw seal the tops of
the bags to keep the pecans fresh and
extend their shelf life ready for retail
consumers won't have any trouble
cracking these pecans they can go
straight to snacking